guys I'm going to point for an Applause
and then I'm going to do the intro is
that good okay all
right let's go come on guys yeah
welcome ladies and gentlemen today we
have a very special event all
right uh welcome ladies and gentlemen uh
today we have a very special event many
Americans are calling the 202 for uh the
election the most important of Our
Generation the future of our great
nation hangs in the balance today value
tment is hosting our second town hall
with a candidate who comes from one of
America's most iconic political
dynasties his commitment to Justice and
government transparency has ignited the
spirit of positive change in millions of
Voters but first please help me welcome
to the stage a bestselling author who
coached us through our next five moves
moves and is now teaching us to choose
our enemies wisely put your hands
together right now for the founder and
CEO of value tment and my friend Patrick
Bet
David how you
doing
okay grab seats grab
seats so the format is going to be an
interest I've been looking forward to
this for a while there's a couple things
I want you to know before we get started
uh one I will go through my questions
some of you have given your questions to
Kelly I will come through uh whenever it
comes time for you to come up you will
simply walk up over here if V hasn't
already told you you'll ask your
question to the candidate Bobby and we
will take it from there but I want to
properly introduce Bobby uh from my
point of view not the one that a lot of
other people maybe know of course we all
know the last name Kennedy it's one of
the greatest last names in American
history political history
when you say what is the most popular
famous last name in America Kennedy is
going to be on that list if you talk
about somebody that a lot of people
claim they want to make the environment
better only a few people dedicated
Decades of their lives being an
environmental lawyer that's what he's
done I can go on and on and on talking
about imagine you being raised in an
environment where your father was
assassinated your uncle who was a
president was assassinated your father
is supposed to be a president he gets
assassinated you got all this stuff
going on and you choose to leave the
Democratic party to run as an
independent no when Thanksgiving is
going to be awkward with your family
where everyone's going to say what are
you doing we're Democrats we're
kennedies you're not supposed to be
doing this there's a lot of things I can
say about that but I
just not agree on everything politically
you're not supposed to but I knew he was
a True Believer three and a half years
ago maybe four years ago I'm in Dallas
he's going to remember this he may
remember this I'm in Dallas and Jennifer
comes up to me telling me uh babe sena's
got to get all her uh vaccine shots I
said and well I'm trying to get an
exemption and they're giving us a hard
time on some of the vaccines I don't
want to get what do we I said bab the
kids going to private school you can do
whatever you want to do with this she
says no babe they're not letting me do
this I said well it's 11:00 at night by
the way I said let me text Bobby he'll
probably get back to me tomorrow and
maybe he's got any kind of feedback to
give me I text him okay we go to sleep
like we're ready to go to sleep boom to
minutes later he's calling me I said
Bobby what's going on I says Patrick you
can't do this let me tell you why he's
on the phone with me telling me what to
do and what not to them what options to
consider as a parent then he's three-way
other people and for 45 minutes we're on
the phone you're trying to figure out
what to do with it I get off the phone
it's midnight I'm like listen we're in
Texas Texas is not Eastern Standard Time
he lives in East Coast maybe maybe he
wasn't there but I said babe this guy
just spent 45 minutes of his evening on
the phone we've never broke bread it's
not like I'm part of of family we're
best friends we're hanging out all the
time we've never had that kind of a
relationship we met a couple times we've
done a couple podcasts together shows
together in that moment I knew this man
was a True Believer obviously two years
later he announces that he's running so
whether you agree with his policies or
not there's a lot of things we'll
question here today there's a lot of
things we'll talk about today you have
to respect respect the fact that this is
not just a man that writes a book to
sell copies he actually believes in what
he talks about having said that please
stand up and put your hands together for
the one and only Robert Kennedy
[Applause]
Jr thank you thank you thank you
please okay you brought the tea
fantastic uh Kelly you are you going to
be the one that's going to be leading
them to go over there is that what the
setup's going to be fantastic okay okay
thank you so let's get right into it how
you doing by the way how you feeling
very well you're good yeah okay so uh I
got the topics to go through um before
even getting into it today it seems like
the political climate is changing all
the time there's a lot of different
things going on uh we have a GOP debate
going on tonight that's taking place I
believe in Alabama last week the santis
and Nome had a debate together uh and
they're having different discussions the
first opening question I'll ask you is
with that debate here's a man uh
possibly the best governor in the way
they handle covid
uh uh Governor Dan santis of Florida he
caused me to come down here because I
felt very free being here who's a
presidential candidate okay going up
with somebody who is not a candidate
he's in a lot of stories people saying
he is he's not you know Biden's going to
step down it's going to be Newsome doing
it you know kamala's in the way but
Newsome's the one that's going to be
president and I'm not going to be doing
it the debate takes place on every
fact the santis had the edge on the
results in the state ofal state of
Florida versus California results came
back at 52% new some
winning your thoughts on watching that
debate with the santis and Nome did you
watch it saying a candidate running
against a non-candidate did you have an
opinion about it was that the right move
was that not the right move what were
your thoughts when you saw that last
week well I I I I have to be clear I did
not see the debate okay oh I um my wife
I was traveling at the time my wife
Cheryl watched the debate and my kids
watched the debate and you know there
I've known um I know uh Governor D
santis and I admired the way that he
handled Co I thought it was him you know
he he took the three
greatest epidemiologists and and
biostatisticians and um and medical
researchers in the country and he he did
something nobody else in the country did
which is he brought them to California
and he said you know what should we be
doing what are the Alternatives the
government is telling us to do this and
he really he allowed a scientific debate
that occur and that's what we should
have been doing everywhere you want P
pandemic management to be transparent
you want it to be open to debate you
want people who disagree with it be to
be able to talk about it and that was
not
happening and I commend governor
desandis for that I think the management
of the debate in California was of the
pandemic in California was among the
worst was the worst in our country they
kept they extended the lockdowns further
than anybody else the the children were
worse damaged than anybody else we're
seeing that now that our Mas scores have
plummeted all of the we now have all of
these learning delays speech
delays the CDC
actually has been forced to re
recalibrate its uh its Milestones so the
CDC provides Milestones that children
for example children are supposed to be
able to walk at 12 months and they're
supposed to have eight uh 30 no 50 words
by 18 months they've now changed that so
children normal children have are walk
by 18
months and that they have 50 year 50
words by
uh I think 36
months so they normalized the injuries
that they did to our children during a
lockdown by simply changing the
milestones and you know the worst at off
was
California I I've known Governor Nome
for for decades I knew his dad I think
that he is a very very formidable
debater he's very um I think you know he
he is he's got kind of everything he's
got every gift he's very attractive he's
very elequent he's articulate about the
way he
talks but I do think that he has a very
difficult record to to defend in
California so um I don't know exactly
what happened to debate but a lot of
times uh the debates are um people judge
the debate based upon how you carry
yourself and he really
um you know he is uh uh he is Allstar at
how he presents himself to the public so
I think that probably helps him a lot do
you think he'd be a good president for
the United States I don't you know
looking at what's happened in California
I don't I don't think it's right for the
United States right
now I think you know I've been to I
spent a year almost a year in uh in San
Francisco um argu in the Monsanto cases
so we went to court with about I think
we had 2400 cases of Mainly Home
gardeners who had gotten non hodkin
lymphoma from using
Roundup and the way that you all of
those cases our cases were Consolidated
with cases from about three other law
firms in front of judges in California
so with the way that multi- District
litigation works you try those cases one
at a time
and usually after you try three or four
or five of them the defendant comes to
the negotiating table you know now the
value of each of those
cases and the defendant comes to the
negotiating table and they settle all of
them by the end we had about 40,000
cases and uh we tried three in a row the
first one we won 89 million on the
second one the jury gave us 289
million the third one we asked for a
billion it was a couple who had both got
on hod lymphoma they both did home
gardening together they sprayed round up
every day they had a laborador retriever
who came with them every day when they
Garden the laborador retriever gun on
Hodgkins and foma and both of them were
diagnosed at the same time the laborator
died um and the jury get we asked the
jury for a billion dollars and they came
back with $2.2
billion and at that point Monsanto came
to the negotiating table and we settled
all the cases but I had to stay in San
Francisco for the better part of a year
arguing those
cases every
morning I went to Union Square to
exercise before court there a gym there
and Union Square in San Francisco is
like Fifth Avenue in New York it has all
of the big uh you know American brands
it has uh nor Nordstrom's Bloomingdale's
Macy's Gap Old Navy uh Levi and it has
the big foreign Brands the big you know
Flag ship stores for de Valley Prada
Gucci farama Burberry people come from
all over the world to shop there I went
there a month ago and every one of those
stores is shut down it's just acre after
acre of plywood because of the chaos in
the street and um you know it's not
hygienic lot of people would say it's
not
safe there's open air drug markets and
you know it's a combination of things
that have caused that it's high housing
prices and it was the lockdowns and I
think the
management uh is uh in California from
the state government and the city
government of San Francisco has been on
has not is not a winning record let me
just put it that way and I think it's a
very very hard record for a governor to
run on do do you by any chance I mean
you have to be a strategist and when
you're talking to your group do you I'm
sure the right answer is going to be
well we're just going to talk about what
our values and principles are and that's
what we're going to talk about policies
do you at all think President Biden is
going to be the candidate on the left at
the end I don't know okay you know I
watched the debate with uh president
Trump last night on Hannity and he was
asked that question and he said he did
not believe that Biden would President
Biden sorry was going to make it to the
end um and I I think by that he meant
that he would drop out at some point or
maybe you know that if he were if he
were going to drop
out the time to drop out would be during
the convention because then he would he
would control the delegates because
they're all Biden
delegates and he would then be able to
pick his successor but I don't know I
anything I say about it is speculation I
try not to speculate way um but I I
don't you know I don't feel like he is
um that he has let me put it this way
the
energy um that we need at this point to
run the country during a period of our
history that is uh you know very
challenging the world is you
know we're in all kinds of Wars we
actually are you know people are
actually talking about using nuclear
weapons now and uh strategic tactical
nuclear weapons for the first time in my
life since I was a kid since you know
the 60s and during that I was uh I was
about 9 years old during the Cuban
Missile Crisis 1962 62 the you I have 11
brothers and sisters there 11 of us and
the US Marshals came to our house there
was a 13-day period during the Cub
Missile Crisis when a lot of Americans
felt that we may all you know Wake Up
Dead the next day
we were we were the closest in human
history that we had ever come to Global
Annihilation and um the US Marshals came
to our house to take myself and my elder
brother Joe to a uh to a an underground
city in the Blue Ridge Mountains in in
West Virginia it's a
place where the whole they have they
have plac for the whole government to
weather the you
know nuclear a thermonuclear
cataclysm and I had heard about it and I
thought I really wanted to see the place
you know there was there's apparently
there were McDonald's there this was
when McDonald's was just invented and
there was shopping centers and all kinds
of stuff and I you know we had watched
science fiction films and watched you
know this
dystopian um you know science fiction um
depiction so I wanted to go there my
father called called us he spent 13 days
on a Cod at the White House during that
period and he called us cuz he knew the
US Marshals were there and he said you
can't go with them and he said um he
said number one if you don't show up at
Our Lady of Victory School everybody in
the country is going to know about it
and they're going to panic and so you
have to be good soldiers and show up at
school but he also said to us during
that uh during that phone call if there
is is a nuclear exchange it would be
better to be the people who are dead and
the people who are left and that's how
he was looking I didn't agree with that
by the way but um that's how he was
looking at the time and I think you know
that kind of fear that he had about you
know about the use the first use of a
nment
weapon is something that we are not
seeing in these kind of anonymous men
and lanyards men and women who are now
making making these calls from the White
House and uh uh you know that worries me
a lot that they're not that there these
are people we don't even know who they
are is um you know I I think the uh the
the people who are calling the shots on
foreign policy are not making good
judgments right now that was supposed to
happen under Trump a lot of people said
when Trump was running everybody thought
there was going to be a nuclear war and
it was actually a time of peace and the
person that was supposed to bring all of
us together that's when the chaos have
been so a lot of people think about that
but let's talk about you as a candidate
as an independent candidate a lot of
times when we think about third party
independent candidate we typically go to
Ros perau and we'll go to Ros perau he
went to 19% and he would get up with his
charts and show what he showed and in
George boy senior's documentary which is
a great documentary to watch there's
only one thing he wouldn't comment on
and matter of fact he got upset and that
to stop the interview with the camera
when they asked him about Ras pero
because it was due to Ras pero that
senior became a one-term president
president that's what a lot of people
will say and rosero allowed Clinton to
become a president the same story can be
said about Teddy Roosevelt but you talk
about a lot Teddy's one of the better
presidents we've had in our history but
at one point he was also recent to help
woodro Wilson become a president at the
time when he was running and both of
those candidates helped a liberal become
a president so that is typically we'll
go back look at a case study and we said
but that's kind of looks like the
trajectory where you're at today when
you hear people say uh according to data
this is just what the numbers will tell
us if it's just Trump against Biden
Biden has a one-point lead okay if it's
just them going up against each other
this is the Quinny pack uh uh uh numbers
that came up but if it's you Trump and
uh Biden he has a three or 4% lead which
means you're helping Biden out what do
you say to the people who like your PO
who like many of your policies who like
the fact that you're pushing the
establishment but at the same time
aren't you just kind of helping
President Biden become a president again
and get reelected well I I mean you know
my my purpose is to win the election so
I want to spoil the election for
President Biden and president
Trump my numbers right now are better
than any independent candidate in 100
years at this point in the election so
you know you have to go back to Teddy
Roosevelt
and we don't really have even good polls
for where he was at this point but you
know Teddy Roosevelt had been
president had made a commitment to not
run for president at the outset and then
um his uh um his vice president who he
was very close to and they were
politically aligned President
Taft ran to replace him and in the
middle of it he in the middle of the
election he got um uh frustrated and and
announced his own run as a as as The
Bull Moose Party and he had you know he
did take the
election away from Taft and gave it to
woodo Wilson I wouldn't call woodo
Wilson a liberal I you know I think
woodo Wilson was uh very uh regressive
on a lot of on on most of his policies
the one thing that he promised to
do is to keep the country out of War
which is a promise that he violated that
he got in there and and got into World
War I um so I you know my polls right
now I'm beating both candidates in all
Americans o under 45 years old and
Americans under 35 years old I'm beating
them both by 10
points I'm up to now uh 24% average in
the Battleground states which puts me
within 10 points of winning the election
all I only have to win a third of the
votes to win the one one vote over a
third so I can win a um I can win the
election theoretically with
34% and I'm already at 24% in key States
like Michigan I think I'm up to 26 or
27 and I have almost a full year and
this was is with spending very very
little money compared to them I'm I'm
leading with independent voters I'm at
36 with independent voters and president
Trump is at 27 I think and uh President
Biden is at is at
31 I'm leading I'm we're essentially in
a three-way tie with Hispanic
voters the only voters that I don't do
well with I'm I'm I'm leading everybody
with mothers who have children at home
so the mothers of children with under 18
the only group that I don't I don't do
well in are uh Baby Boomers and I
believe that the reason and I can't
prove
this I believe the reason that I'm not
doing well with them is that they all
they get their news from television from
MSNBC from CNN and then from The New
York Times And The Washington Post and
if
I if that was the news bubble that I was
living in I would have a very low
opinion of myself as
well and those those uh news outlets
will not let me on they will not let me
debate they won't let me talk they will
not give a uh a live interview with me
sometimes a couple of them have said
we'll interview you but it will be live
to tape which means they can interview
me for 20 minutes and take a 10-second
you know sound bite out of that to to
distort or whatever but I think that's
beginning to change and now we're seeing
changes in that and I believe like my
kids I have seven kids and I would
believe that none of them have ever
watched a evening news on TV they get
their news from other sources they get
it from the internet they get it from
podcast
Etc and in that generation I am
dominating so and what we're seeing
anecdotally is that people who watch my
interviews long form
interviews even liberal Democrats has
have a very very high conversion rate so
my strategy over the next uh 11 months
is to get as many of those people to be
able to see interviews with me to ask me
questions to um and you know to get to
know something about me that's outside
this kind of Stew of defamations and
pejoratives that you know Define me in
the in the mainstream media but I you
know I'm very confident that we're going
to win the race I don't think
I'm running against the two I think
weakest candidates in in American
history president Trump has a very very
um intense
following but it's relatively small and
President Biden there's almost nobody
that I've met in fact I can say I've
never met anybody so
far who says you should vote for
President Biden because he has a a great
vision for the country that he's
energetic that he can grapple with the
big problems and they all say you got to
vote for him because otherwise Trump is
going to start a
dictatorship and you know we've got to
do more the Democratic party has to do
more than just offer people you know the
the the the L of two evils and you know
and say to them and appeal to their fear
these young kids that you know I that
who are following me are people who want
hope for their future they want a vision
for our country they want to be proud of
our country there's a there was a poll
taken in
2013 that showed that Americans between
18 and 35 years old when asked 85% they
were said they were proud of the United
States of America the same poll taken
last month of the same group of people
only 18% said they were proud of our
country to me that's the most
heartbreaking data point I've seen since
has began and you've got a whole
generation of kids who've lost faith in
the United States of America and they've
lost any hope that they have for their
kids sometime in the last eight
years during the administrations of the
two people I'm running against this
generation has completely lost hope and
you know we got to offer them something
better and you should be scared of the
other guy we have to tell them they're
going to be able to buy a home you know
that they're going to that you know know
our our moral Authority as a nation is
going to be restored that we're going to
rebuild the middle class in this country
that we're going to end the chronic
disease epidemic that is debilitating
60% of the people in their
generation we're going to end this
corrupt merger of state and corporate
power that has you know left all of our
Regulatory Agencies as as captives of
the industries they're supposed to
regulate as Predators against the people
of this
country and
you know I'm running against two guys
two men former presidents who both say
they're running on the idea that they
brought tremendous prosperity to our
country and I sit at kitchen tables with
people a lot with a regular Americans I
did this before I ran because I
represent them in
lawsuits and you know when you tell
people you're experiencing this
extraordinary Prosperity right now you
know they feel like they're being
gaslighted there's nobody there's nobody
in that generation there's
nobody who's under 20 who's under 30
years old who thinks that they're ever
going to buy a house you know the
housing price have gone from $215 two
years ago to$ 400,000 today and the
interest rates have gone from 3 to
almost 8% and you know and corporations
are buying the houses but your but kids
are not oh and we got to offer them
something different we got to do
something different the let these you
know kids have a hope in our country and
in their own future again I think
there's another reason why Boomers you
don't do well with Boomers the day I'll
tell you I think you're not your
marketing team's got to pay attention to
this the day you took your shirt off and
started doing push-ups you pissed off a
lot of Boomers yes or no I think when
people saw how jacked he was they're
like wait a minute take that video away
from my wife I don't want people to see
this honey how come you can't bench like
Bobby can't anyways that's just my
speculation little bit of research for
you so let's go to this with the
independent becoming a president um 2020
it was estimated that the two major
party nominees spend 1.4 billion on
their campaign okay that's up from 1.1
billion in 16 and 660 in 2012 they're
saying it's going to be around $2
billion today some are even saying it's
going to be around $3 to4 billion you
raised $8.7 million in the last quarter
Tony Lions who is co-founder of the
American values said he'll pledge $15
million and then at the same time this
is all great when you're going around
saying you know you're getting $5 $10
donations uh if we wanted to do $5
donations to get to a billion dollars
for you to run for office you would need
200 million people Americans to donate
$5 and then at the same time that
includes the last time we had around 157
150 whatever amount of people that voted
so there's a lot of people that how are
you going to raise that kind of money to
run for office while many billionaires
are sitting there or even guys that are
are willing to put the packs they're
saying am I going to go here you see Ken
Griffin they're leaning towards Nikki
Haley you're seeing you know even Jamie
Diamond leaning towards you know do you
feel you need to take money from some of
these folks like do you feel you need to
raise real money to get there and is
there anybody you wouldn't take money
from such as fizer yeah I I I don't
think I have to worry about fizer giving
me money and turning it down what if one
day they say we endorse RFK if you
change your you know what I listen
they're not going to do that but I'm
going to um you know I mean they'd be
fired by their board if they did that I
they story though they should be but um
the answer to your question your your s
broader question is uh first of all I've
outraised last quarter I outraised both
president Trump and President Biden with
uh my campaign did I and I don't know
exactly what the numbers are but you
know we raised over $8 million and I
think they raised six and five that's
the campaign the campaign has a maximum
donation level of of 6600 under federal
law oh and it's it's what we did there
is the hardest thing to do which is to
raise small dollar donations and we
started out with a list of only1 15,000
people we get about $38 per name per
quarter um Bernie had about 13 million
people oh he didn't have to raise any
corporate money because he was getting
20 or 30 bucks a person per quarter and
just do that math you know if you get in
your head and he didn't need corporate
money he didn't need billionaire money
so you can do it you know what we need
is to build our list size and that's one
of the things that we're
doing then the super packs the the big
money money that you were talking about
is coming not through the campaigns it's
coming from the super
packs who we are not allowed to
coordinate with it's against the law for
us to coordinate it but the super Pacs
try to look at what you're doing and do
what you would want them to do it's a
messed up system I'm not defending it
I'm just saying how it works um and the
super pack the the that super pack you
mentioned which is the American value
Super PAC has raised some something
close I don't know exactly to $30
million so we're getting real money
coming in and by the way with that 8
million that we had we are now beating
President Biden and president Trump and
young people were beating them with
Independence these the key demographics
and we're beating them with a lot of
others um and that's with me only
running for the past 6 and a half months
so I have 11 months in front of me and I
feel like you know with a tiny fraction
of the money they make that I can win
the election but we're going to we're
going to get money we're going to money
is coming in
now and um you know and we will uh and
you know we'll have enough money to put
on a a real national campaign and to get
on the ballot it
causes $15 million to get on the ballot
in every
estate president Trump and President
Biden don't have to do that because the
Democratic party and the Republican
Party are already on the ballot so we
have to do something something they
can't do and what they're going to do is
try to stop
me I'm getting on the ballot by by
putting legal impediments and uh um and
doing everything they can to make sure
that the American people don't get a
choice and you know what I would say to
you is that um whether you're a
Republican or Democrat whether you like
me or somebody else that American should
have that
choice and one of the things that you
can do is to go to our website kennedy4
and um and and you can sign a ballot
petition from your state on that
website uh so even if you don't intend
to vote for me in the end I think and if
you do believe in American democracy and
believe that it's beneficial for a
democracy to have as many choices
possible please go and and sign that
petition next question uh big Pharma is
something that is uh probably one of
your biggest enemies if not your biggest
enemy when you said they're not going to
endorse me of course they're not going
to endorse you because you've uh you've
kind of gone in their way you've called
them out I remember I got a strike for
one of the interviews we did with you by
the way years ago when we had you on you
remember that when we I apologize it's
totally fine it was worth it it was a
great conversation that we had you're
welcome you're welcome yeah but where
I'm going with this is the following
here's my concern uh I think three
things are keeping cable TV in business
one are your friends the Boomers okay
two is Big Pharma and three is sports a
lot of sport sports team are going away
and they're saying hey you can watch us
on our own Ott you don't need to go to
NBC whatever to watch it you can come to
us baby boomers just a matter of time
and the third one keeping Cable in
business is Big Pharma around $5.7
billion big Pharma gave to cable TV in
20122 now two countries in the world are
the only countries where big Pharma can
advertise in it's us and it's uh New
Zealand right um I'm having this
conversation with vivec back there in
the Cigar Lounge uh uh about a month ago
on his podcast
and I
said why are we allowing big Pharma to
advertise and they're almost forcing all
these mainstream media Talking Heads
that are reading a teleprompter to do
whatever they tell them to do because if
you don't you're not going to get the
money and all this stuff they're pretty
much puppets for them and that's not
that's not a that's a reality when
you're seeing it that's their job that's
who pays them their millions of dollars
per year and I said why why are we
allowing big farmer out say well this is
because capitalism so somebody can come
and says what if a car you can kill
people with cars are we going to ban
cars I said but why do we ban cigarettes
you can buy cigarettes but you don't see
ads on TV You Don't See maror You Don't
See Winston why don't we ban big Pharma
from advertising 195 countries in the
world only two of them allowed we're one
of them are you someone that's you know
has the courage or thinks it's a good
idea if in the day you become a
president well you will prevent big FMA
from advertising on cable TV the answer
to that is yes do that on day one but
it's let me well I'll explain how it
works and let me ask you something what
did what did VC say vivec said let me go
research it and I'm want to I'm going to
think but he said it's a very good idea
I said the reason why I think you ought
to think about it is because his
background as well and that conversation
led to I got to go do more due diligence
while we're doing the interview we're
checking what companies cannot advertise
and the one we found is tobacco you my
dad actually got got uh cigarette ads
off of TV and um and and got liquor ads
off of TV if you
remember 10 years ago even you never saw
liquor hat on TV that's recent that
you're seeing that they on on the on the
network news the liquor
companies my father actually threatened
had legislation to ban them and they
came to him and said look don't ban us
we will just stop doing it we won't
advertise on T so um gradually you got
it so there were be beer ads on TV but
hard liquor companies did not advertise
on TV probably till 10 or 15 years ago I
don't know exactly when they but I
remember when they you started seeing
Vlad ads and then you know more and more
stuff and it was on cable TV it was not
on networks it was not on ABC NBC CBS
because the public actually owns the
network owns those
Airways the uh the companies that you
know the broadcasters have a license to
use them but they have to use them in
ways that promote the public interest
and it was it was regarded at that time
that direct consumer advertisement was
bad everybody agreed with that the
American Medical Association everybody
agreed you we should not be doing direct
to
Consumer advertising pharmaceutical that
changed in
1997 so that's when you started seeing
this wave of pharmaceutical ads on TV
and of course
the the pharmaceutical companies want to
advertise on the network news for two
reasons one is because it because that's
where their customers are the only
people as I
said who watch Network news are old
people and those are people who are
buying the pharmaceutical trucks right
and then the um and the other reason is
because it allows them to control
content oh and you know other companies
do this too like you'll see
you know north of Grumman and Ron and
lock you know I I saw on ad the other
day I think it was on Good Morning
America it was one of the big where they
were advertising killer drones and I was
like who watching this show is buying
killer drones of course nobody is but it
allows them to control the content and
to get there you know all the former
generals who who act as experts on the
on the mainstream media and or
constantly telling the nor War narrative
and getting us you know so they that's
one of the reason they doing a farma um
in 20 I think it was 20 yeah
2014 I had a conversation with Roger
alss do you guys know who Roger ales is
raise your hand if you know who he
is so most of you do Roger alses was the
founder of Fox
News and I spent when I was 18 years old
or 19 years old I spent 3 months in a
tent with him in East Africa and that's
a long
story but I remained friends with him
this is before Fox News existed I remain
friends with him and he later started
Fox News and for me ideologically he was
like Darth
Vader but our friendship we had a a very
very close friendship even though we
were politically diametrically opposed
to each other and he would put me on I
you know I was always uh fighting for
the environment I was the the leading
Environmental Lawyer and advocate in the
country I was the only environmentalist
who went on Fox News one because the
other ones didn't want to do it but also
Roger would make Shan Hannity and Neil
Cavuto and Bill O'Reilly and all of his
hosts put me on even though he didn't
agree with what I was
saying and so I did in 2014 I did a a a
documentary with some other people about
Mercury and
vaccines and I went to Roger alss I
showed it to him and he said yeah you
know and in fact he believed that one of
that a relative of his had been injured
was you know was severely
injured he said I can't let you on with
that and he said in fact if any of my
hosts allowed you onto their shows I
would have to fire them really and yeah
and he said if I didn't I remember this
this is a quote he said if I didn't fire
them I would I would have rert I which
he meant rert Murdoch the owner of the
network on the telephone within 10
minutes and then he said to me
75% of the advertising revenues for our
evening news show are coming from Pharma
and he
said out of typically 22 to 24 news shot
news slots I mean advertising slots on
the evening news 17 are going to
pharmaceutical
companies and so he said you know and
I've seen time and time again where
hosts are are you know get calls from
the corporate and from the bean counters
who are doing the
advertising where News hosts get that
and say you know that that that segment
I just taped with you we can't play it
because our advertisers are telling us
not to and I can recite stories like
that with names and dates all day I've
written about it but you know that it is
the reality that the pharmaceutical
industry that the people like Anderson
Cooper like uh Jake Tapper are really uh
are pharmaceutical reps you know their
job is to drum up fear of infectious
disease and uh and stories about chronic
disease and then to self pharmaceutical
advertising on TV and if you you know
their salaries ultimately not directly
But ultimately are coming from uh the
pharmaceutical industry Lely it would be
very funny if if somebody at CNN who's
an editor I'm not trying to give anybody
any ideas but maybe if they're a fan of
RFK while Anderson Cooper is doing it on
the bottom instead of saying host he
says you know pharmaceutical rep for
fizer it'd be very entertaining not
trying to put any ideas in any 24
year-old editor's Minds at CNN I just
thought it'd be funny anyway so next
topic okay it's not good career advice
Hy it's definitely not good but we're
hiring over here so maybe it be a a good
opportunity to come somewhere else okay
you've been
accused of claiming that man-made
chemicals in the environment are making
children gay or transgender and causing
Fe feminization of boys and
masculinization of grows this has been
shown even with Bill Maher that he
showed Generation by Generation by
generation we're getting gayer and gayer
and gayer eventually in the next 20
years you and I end up being gay the way
we're going right now in a June
2022 episode of your podcast you stated
if you expose frogs to atrazine male
frogs it changes their sex and they can
actually be young they can lay eggs this
is you're saying this fertile eggs and
so the capacity for these chemicals that
we are just raining down on our children
right now in to induce them these very
profound sexual changes in them is
something we need to be thinking about
as a society and even according to a
report particles can harm human body
estimate s of the total mass of ingested
MP particles correspond to 50 plastic
bags per year this is all of us in here
One credit card per week or median value
of you know other numbers we can look at
here but this is kind of the other day I
have bathroom in my office only two of
us use this it's me and Vinnie you know
somebody goes to the bathroom they
forget to flush it you see something the
other day I go to the bathroom I'm
looking at there's six credit cards in
the bathroom Vinnie was you know because
he's got so much plastic in his body
that you know for us with the wrong
chemicals that we have nain is still
straight he we're good with him but how
do you when you say something like this
there's only one other guy that said
this about frogs and he had to pay a few
hundred million find they trying to get
the money from him I'm not going to go
there but how do you plan to combat the
poisoning of Americans if elected
president well first of all let me
clarify something I never said that
chemicals in our um in our food or water
are making people gay I've never said
that um I never said that they're making
people
TR um or or giving them sexual
dimorphism um here's what I did say
first of all I've worked for I've spent
40 years working on endocrine disruptors
and it's noncontroversial endocrine
disruptor is a family of chemicals that
has the impact on sexual development of
human humans and of animals and you know
there are many including you know pbas
and
plastic um uh and uh pcbs uh which are a
flame
retardant and many many other chemicals
that are known to have the impact of of
endocrine disruption they they disrupt
in mammals and other
animals normal sexual development so
that that is non controversial nobody
disagrees with that um the the the study
that I referred to and any of you can
look this up on your cell phones right
now on
Google is a study in which a scientist
uh and I I I can't remember his last
name I know his first name is Tyler um
but you can look it up and you can use
it first thing but you don't even need
to do that you just put atrazine and
sexual dimorphism or sexual changes in
frogs and that's going to come up on
your Google you're going to see a
peer-reviewed published study what he
did is he took 27 frogs
males he put them in aquarium and he
exposed them to levels of
atrazine that are
below EPA exposure levels so they're
they're below the levels that we are
receiving
63% of the water supply is now
contaminated with
atrin and EPA allows that up to
levels up to a certain level before it
tells you the local water district stop
people from drinking it and that level
that they
allow is what Tyler exposes the frogs to
so they're 27
frogs he expose them to the chemicals
and they're all
male um of that 90% of
them uh went were became sterile they
could not produce
young
10% I think three of the frogs um became
uh turned
female and were capable of producing
fertile eggs so their sex was literally
Changed by exposure to this chemical now
what I
said is that there are antidotal
observational evidence that we are
seeing higher numbers of of of
individuals with sexual dimorphism than
in previous generations that is
controversial because they people out
there will say no it's always been
steady but there's a lot of people and
there's some studies that show no it's
actually increasing dramatically I'm not
going to take aide one way or the other
but if it is
increasing shouldn't we look first of
all shouldn't we do studies to see if
it's increasing that's what the federal
government should be doing but they
won't do
them second of all shouldn't we be doing
studies to see if there if the the
chemicals that we know impact frogs that
way whether they also impact humans that
way and there's easy ways to study that
without deliberately
exposing humans to do those chemicals so
shouldn't we be doing those studies
whether not just adrine but other
endocrine disruptors that are now
ubiquitous everybody in the Hudson
Valley has General Electrics pcbs and
their flesh and our
organs a lot of these chemicals are now
that are known endocrine disruptors are
ubiquitous now and shouldn't we be
determining whether they're having these
other Insidious effects on us and that
is all I said now your your question was
how am I going to end that here's how
I'm going to end it my first week in
office I'm going to go to Bethesda where
NIH is and Bethesda and the NIH will not
let you study these questions right now
NIH has an annual budget of $42 billion
it distributes that money to 56,000
scientists in research centers mainly in
universities all across North America
and some in countries as well to study
human health
impacts but what NIH and when I was a
kid NIH was the gold standard research
Agency on
Earth in fact if you went to other
countries in Europe ltin America Africa
they don't they don't have a a
scientific
agency they in fact in their laws they
say whatever FDA approves is approved in
this country whatever NIH says you know
we're going to take their word for it
because they were they were at
impeccable
Integrity what's happened over the past
50 years is NIH has stopped doing that
kind of Science and it's
changed to do science that is corrupt
often times that is used to justify uh
the mertile or promote the Mercantile
Ambitions of the industries that it
regulates but mainly it has become an
incubator pharmaceutical products so for
example the the modna vaccine is owned
by NIH and NIH gets to keep 50% of the
royalties oh they're making tens of
billions from a product that they made
us all
take not only that but there are six
individuals who work for NIH who work uh
top deputies of of um of the vent
manager and Anthony fouchy who also have
walk-in rights for the patents so they
are allowed to collect
$150,000 a year from modna CES forever
their children their children's children
they paying for their boats their
mortgages their uh their kids education
their
alimonies from what they get from from
uh from
Mna and that is not a very good uh it's
not a good idea let me put it that way
you want Regulators to be independent
and you don't want the commercial
Ambitions of individual
Regulators to subvert the regulatory
function of that agency and you give
somebody
$150,000 a year forever their children
their children
children they might Overlook something
some problems with that drug and their
job is to find problems with it and so
um you really think they're going to let
you go expose that I mean Rand Paul's
been trying to do what he's doing you
really think I mean oh well as president
they work for me I you know I've been
suing these agencies for 40
years I know with the regulatory I
understand regulatory capture I I have a
PhD in it at each one of these agencies
I've sued almost all of them I've sued
NIH CDC FDA EPA multiple mult multiple
times I sue do cuz I I'm involved in
litigation now with them apartment of
Transportation because I'm representing
a thousand families right now whose
lives were upended by the Norfolk
Southern spille in East at Palestine
Ohio so I not only am I'm meeting with
them at their kitchen tables and hearing
what it's done to their lives but I'm I
you know I'm seeing and we're
discovering and
Discovery why that was a result of
corporate capture and I'll just tell you
one of the many things you know the FDA
will propos a regulation that there
should be heat Cent sensors on every
wheel of these huge car of these huge
train cars now I mean these huge trains
that have hundreds of cars on them and
every wheel should have a heat sensor on
it to notify the
engineer and and that there should be
multiple engineers and Personnel on each
train the agency because it doesn't want
to spend that money said no we only need
one person on a on a train with 100 cars
on it and we don't want to install the
heat centers cuz that's going to cost us
a couple thousand per
train well we now know that on that
spill the wheel of that train was was
sparking and then it caught fire and for
20 miles it was on fire getting bigger
and bigger until the whole box car
burned and the box car was full of PVC
pipe which went off like an explosion
and um and derailed the train how do we
know because through
Discovery we got the doorbell ringers
from people who were neighbors of that
train track and you can watch it from
their doorbell cameras with this fire
getting bigger and bigger for 20 miles
and the engineer has no idea cuz they
didn't put the heat sensors on so that
spill took place directly because of
agency capture and that's what you see
when we sued I'll tell you very
briefly when we sued
Monsanto we found email correspondence
between the head of the pesticide
division at the EPA for a decade a guy
called Jess
Roland and the top Executives of the
Monsanto company which own Roundup which
we were
suing and they were secret emails where
we believed at the American public
believe was paying just roll and his
salary and we believed he was working
for us from these emails it's clear that
for a decade he was secretly working for
Monsanto and they were telling him kill
this study fix this study don't let this
happen yeah at one point they say oh no
there's another agency atsdr that's
going to study the link between Cancer
and Roundup you cannot let that study
happen J Roland sends him an email back
saying I can't stop it it's not not my
agency and they sent him back saying you
have to stop it and he then says okay
I'm going to do it but you need to give
me a gold
medal that's why we the first two judges
would not let us show that memo to the
jury the third judge did and that's why
they gave us 2.2 billion because they
were Americans and they're upset that
their their Regulators are are owned by
the industry they're supposed to
regulate by the way how much do these
things matter to you like you would want
the president to investigate these
things yes okay let's continue uh Blake
Blake Roth if you can work your way up
to the mic I'll come to you right
afterwards meanwhile I'm going to
continue with this next question here um
according to China uh XO news at least
900 young adults are taking part of
military training with some as young as
7 years old in China we're training boys
at 7 years old in America we're
transitioning boys at 7 years old
according to a new poll conducted by Pew
Research Center in June only 9% of Young
Americans ages 17 to 24 say they are
very or somewhat likely to serve in the
military in the next four years this is
the lowest percentage we've had uh
Express in a military service since 1979
when Pew research started this so here's
what it makes me think about number one
16 years old I need to be to get a
driver's license 18 years old to get a
tattoo 18 years old to vote 21 years old
to drink 25 years old in many states to
get a you know rent a car but California
and some of the directions some places
are going hey your your daughter your
son can run away this is a sanctuary
State and you can come and do a
procedure here without the consent of
your parents what will you do as a
president to get this nonsense out to
prevent kids under the age of 18 with or
without the consent of the father to
transition you may even say that is an
okay policy you're a part of that many
families disagree with one what's your
position on this and what will you do as
a president I mean my my position is
that people should not not be able to
have access to those procedures the
minor shouldn't without parental
permission
and you know I don't I I don't know
enough about it um Patrick to to say
that it should be completely illegal
under 18 no no yeah I just don't know
enough what I what I'm going to tell you
because I don't know well Robert I mean
you're you're I don't you know what I
don't know enough I would I need to look
at Data before I do a make a decision
my my inclination is that it's not good
for anybody there may be some rare
cases where it saves somebody's life I
don't know that and I'm not going to
tell you that I have an answer to a
question ience but Robert there's a big
difference I just want to say there's a
big difference between those two things
one saving somebody's life to transition
and cut the dangling off how are you
saving that person's life some of these
things logically they make no sense to
parents so parents are sitting there you
going to have to answer this for both
parents on both sides there's
conflicting values here and one of the
values is freedom to do what you want
with your own body and have the
government tell you you can or you can't
do that who is protecting kids under the
age of 18 though that's the other right
and that's why it's say nobody can do it
without their parents' permission that's
solid and and then I I have to look at
the drugs the safety of the drugs
whether they there's permanent damage
from the I just don't know you're
rolling your eyes like I should this is
an obvious question do you do you trust
a 14-year-old driving a
car uh without a driver's license do you
trust a 13-year-old voting what if a
parent consents for a 13-year-old to
vote should we be okay with that cuz the
parent said it's okay should we trust
parent 13y old I get that but why should
it be legal for somebody at 13 with
parent consent to
transition well first of all the the
anal the metaphors you gave are not um
are not apt because when you drive a car
you're affecting other
people you're making a decision I'm not
listen I'm not I'm just telling you the
truth I don't have a position on this
because I don't know enough about it I
believe my values are the same as yours
and you probably know a lot more about
this and could explain it to me but you
know I don't know whether there are rare
rare cases my inclination is that we
shouldn't be giving drugs you know we
should limit any kind of drug that is
dangerous that their availability to
young people but there may be some rare
circumstances that you wouldn't want to
criminalize it so you know I I I do
believe is that people who make those
kind of decisions as
adults um should be uh should be that
they shouldn't be subject to ridicule or
derision or bias in any way and that we
should discourage do everything we can
to discourage the those kind of
decisions from young people can I can I
add one other issue please go forward
there's a lot of um of things happening
to our children
now uh that we need to look
at as a nation and that are being
completely
ignored when my uncle was President 6%
of American children had chronic disease
of
Americans uh By and By chronic disease I
mean categories
obesity um neurological injuries like
ADD ADHD speech delay language delay
ticks toured syndrome narcolepsy ASD
autism food allergies peanut allergies
um which I never saw in my life I 11
siblings I have 70 cousins none of them
have food allergies why do five of my
seven kids have those
allergies and then autoimmune
disease um rheumatoid arthritis juvenile
diabetes exotic disease like Crohn's
disease and lupus that we never saw as a
kid a kid
6% I 1986
11.8% by 2006 54% this is one of the the
the the problems with our military
they're not eligible for military
service we don't know what it is today
CU after 2006 ni stopped publishing the
data it's probably 60% of our G kids
have autoimmune allergic or neurological
disease you see epipens in every
classroom you see how but all inhalers
you have in some classes 70% of the kids
are an adderal they're diagnosed with
ADHD what's happening autism went from
one in 10,000 in my
generation to one in every 34 kids today
and it's not cuz we're seeing it
suddenly because then you'd see it in my
generation I've never seen a 69 year man
69y old man with full-blown autism by
that I mean nonverbal non- toilet
train um headbanging stemming toe
walking hand flapping I've never seen
that in a 69y old man in my kids
generation it's one in every 34
kids EPA Congress said to EPA tell us
what year it started the epidemic
started EPA came back EPA is a captive
agency but it's captive by oil coal
chemical and big egg is not caped by
Pharma because it doesn't regulate
Pharma so they came back with an honest
study and they said it's a red line
1989 as it turns
out these diseases most of them started
on that same timeline around 1989 peenut
allergies suddenly appear obesity goes
crazy we go from 6% of having obesity
45% of kids 75% overweight it's not cuz
they suddenly got lazy American
kids it's because they're being Mass
poisoned by something and why aren't we
asking the question what is that what is
happening to American children we have
the highest chronic disease rate of any
nation in the world we have the highest
covid death rates we had 16% of the
covid deaths in this country we only
have 4.2% of the world's population
why is that bad Management number one
and number
two we we it was chronic disease killing
these kids EPA
said of the PE Americans who died from
covid on average they had 3.8 chronic
disease they had
diabetes
asthma uh obesity and one other or some
other
group we have the highest chronic
disease rate in the world and it's
bankrupting us our when my uncle was
present
6% now it's probably 6% but if you look
at Medicare bills we're paying well
we're paying total of 4.3 trillion a
year on on health care and 93% of that
is going to chronic disease it's an
unnecessary cause and nobody's asking
the question why is it
happening well there's a doctor in New
York a toxic very famous toxicologist
called Phil landan
and he he's a guy I've used as an expert
in many cases but he's actually done
done studies and said what could it be
you have to find a
toxin that became ubiquitous in 1989 in
the early 90s and and affected every
demographic in our country from Cubans
and cuas game Inu and Alaska and affects
boys and neurological injuries 4 to1
ratio to girls oh he looked at some of
these questions he said there's only
about 13 things that could possibly
be one of those is glyphosate from round
up one of them is neonic toid pesticides
atrazine which is in 63% of our
water um high fructose corn serup you
know which follows some of that
timeline Wi-Fi radiation from cell
phones which I've one a a case on in the
court of appeals um and then and then
there and a pfoas which is a forever
chemical it's a flame
retardant that was put in all of our
kids pajamas on that timeline and all of
our furniture and there's a few more the
easiest thing in the world is to
actually go do the study identify what
it is that is making Americans so sick
you know and that's that's 93% of our
health care cost let's eliminate those
toxins that's what I'm going to do when
I get in there I'm going to go in and
I'm going to
tell all these scientists from EPA we're
not developing drugs anymore we're going
to give infectious disease a break for a
couple of years and we're going to find
out why are we the sickest people on the
face of the
Earth why is that happening to
America and we should all be talking
about this issue I would love to see you
are you willing to dedicate some of your
time the next couple months to see and
by the way the issue that you rais is
one of the things that needs to be
studied let's look at it and then you
know make it decision based on data and
you know that is consistent with our
values my values on this are the same as
you I just don't have the
confidence that I've talked to enough
people and read enough studies to
actually make a you know a a defensible
decision by saying oh ban this for
everybody I don't know I might somebody
may come to me and say wait a minute my
child's life is Sav I don't know I got a
few more questions I want to go through
but I also want to go to the guest here
Matt if you have your question if you
want to lead the way to next Jonathan GS
and bl Blake rothell afterwards if you
want to go right behind go forward Matt
hi good afternoon my name is Matthew
saala and uh I served eight years in
Marine Corps uh to on active duty 8
years in active duty to the reserves I
served under three different commanders
and Chiefs which is both bushes and the
clintons and my political opinion was
asking fellow crew chiefs how do we vote
how do we vote how do we former
political opinion while serving in the
military so your family's regard as the
most famous political diet Dynasty so
who did you seek councel from and how
did you process leaving the Democratic
party and what should American voters be
specifically aware of in this election
cycle from both sides Democratic and
Republican so you're asking why that I
went first of all thank you for your
service and you're asking why or you
know why I went
independent I I uh I mean I consult with
a lot of people
um my you know my campaign manager at
the time was Dennis gusich who himself
had run for
president very liberal Democrat any war
and um he uh he was one of the first
people that said the democra party is
not going to let you win you're going to
have to leave and I was um I said to him
I'm not going to do that and um and one
by one all of my the people around me
because
it became obvious that the Democratic
party was not going to let me win no
matter what and they changed the
rules or they somebody actually
tabulated 60 different rules they
adopted to make sure that I could not
win even if I got the most votes so for
example I'll just give you one
example they made a rule that if any
candidate which was directed to me
because I'd already done violate this
rule if any candidate stepped into the
state of New Hampshire one foot
in um that all the the votes that uh
that that candidate won in New Hampshire
would not
count that was a rule they proposed the
same rule for Georgia but not about
Georgia they said if anybody's thought
steps foot in New Hampshire they can't
win any votes in Georgia
either um and Iowa and actually they
proposed it for Florida as well but they
did a lot of other things like that they
created this class of of super it's
called plos that even if I
won they could take the election away
from me and then you know President
Biden of course wouldn't debate
me and I it just became you know I had
by that time gotten a lot of money from
people in $5 donations millions of
dollars and a lot of big donors and I
you know feel like I felt like I had an
obligation to do the best um that I
could to win which is why they gave me
the money and not uh and not just have a
Kabuki theater of I'm going to R run and
make a couple of points and then you
know bow
out and
ultimately my wife who's a hardcore
Democrat um you know also said they're
not going to let you do it you got to
leave so I did it you know my my
family's it was uh it was a difficult
decision for me my family's been
involved in the Democratic party for
over a 100 years my family came over and
the potato fam and they all when they
got here you Irish in in Britain had not
been for 600 years had not been allowed
to participate in politics and when they
got here they took the politics like
starving men take the the
food and my uh my grandfather John
Fitzgerald honey Fitz um became the
first Irish Catholic mayor of
Boston the uh his his my other
grandparent great grandparent Patrick
Kennedy
great uh what now this is you're talking
about my grandfather his son Patrick
Kennedy um was in the state legislature
and was a ward boss a big political boss
in in
Boston and their kids uh Rose Kennedy
and Joseph Kennedy married each other
and then produced nine
kids uh their eldest boy Joe was killed
in World War I on a on a very very
dangerous volunteer mission after he had
completed all of his flights he was
asked
to um or he volunteered to fly the first
flying bomb which was a remote
controlled plane that they were going to
uh they were going to direct into the
submarine pens the Nazi submarine
pens and the plane was controlled by
another plane with a remote control
first time in history that had happened
but they needed a pilot to take it off
and it was loaded with
bombs and he took it off and got it to
altitude and he was the great hope for
my f family in fact 40 years after his
death my grandfather if you mention his
name would burst into tears now he loved
that child so much and uh when they got
to altitude and turned on the remote
control the whole plane vaporized and he
his body was never found so he died his
younger brother John Kennedy Jack was
the first Irish Catholic mayor of of our
country and um I mean president of our
country my my dad was attorney general
was killed running for president my
Uncle Teddy was in the senate for 50
years longer than anybody else except
for one other
Senator um my brother was you know I
don't know seven or eight terms in
Congress my sister was lieutenant
governor of of Maryland a lot of my
cousins are in political or we're in
political
office my name is almost synonymous with
the da modern democratic party so it was
uh for me to walk away from that was a
very very difficult decision and I you
know for me to run for president that's
not something I ever intended to
do um I have uh you know and I but all
of these decisions are are novel
decisions for me that I've been I'm
making because I think it's you know the
that I I feel like I'm in a unique
position to fix this corrupt merger of
state and corporate power that has
locked in on our competent country and
converted us into a into a Imperium
abroad a militarized State abroad a
surveillance State at
home and put corporations in charge of
our democracy rather than people and I
feel like I'm in a because of my history
because of my family connections my name
recognition and my experience unraveling
corporate power um that I'm in a unique
position to be able to fix a lot of
these things thank you for that so I got
a question here about Israel and
Palestine and Hamas but I going to bring
in something you said about climate
change a few months ago you said in May
2nd 2023 on an interview with unheard
the crisis of climate change has been to
some context co-opted by Bill Gates and
the world economic forum and the
billionaires boys club in Davos the same
way that covid crisis was appropriated
by them to make themselves richer to
impose totalitarian controls and to
stratify our society with very powerful
wealthy people at the top and the vast
majority of human beings with very
little power and very little sovereignty
over their own lives every crisis is an
opportunity for those to combat for uh
for those to clamp down controls okay so
this is what you said a few months ago
let's set this aside this just comes out
recently uh with Israel and Palestine
Gaza you know Hamas we're seeing all
these uh travesties the stories all of
them we've been following according to
an article from New York Times that came
out November 30 a week ago Israeli
officials obtained hamas's battle plan
for the October 7 terrorist attack more
than a year before it happened but
Israeli military and intelligence
officials dismissed the plan as
aspirational considering it to too
difficult to carry out similar to how
President Bush was warned of terrorist
attack threats from Osama Bin Laden and
Al-Qaeda August 6 2020 uh 2001 36 days
before 911 attacks earlier this week a
report from CNN indicated that bets
against the value of Israeli companies
spiked in the days before October 7th
Hamas attacks suggesting some Traders
may have had Advanced knowledge of the
looming terror attack and profited off
of it similar to the knowledge they had
the unusual Market activity and short
selling of United Airlines and American
airline stock on September 10th 2001 a
day before 9911 now do you believe if
you're able to make this statement about
climate change and how they use covid
today American people's trust in the
government it's the lowest it's ever
been in the mainstream media it's the
lowest it's ever been when you read
articles like this the American voter
system says who the hell can I trust do
you think there was any ill intentions
here uh I don't think that the evidence
that you just presented is uh um
is evidence uh necessarily of Israeli uh
government complicity or for knowledge
there first of
allas it's self is a an extraordinary
wealthy organization that has you know
it's all of its top officials literally
all of them are billionaires the top
three people Ismael um AA and his two
top
cohorts ismaela has5 billion that he
stolen from you know International Aid
yaser Arafat was a billionaire his wife
is a billionaire mmud abas who's the uh
who's the current director of the West
Bank is a billionaire his two sons of
$750
million um Hamas has a war chest of in
real real estate and and stock
Investments of uh $500
million their biggest sponsor is Iran
who plan the attack and Iran also uh you
know there's people in Iran who if they
had forign knowledge could or bad on it
um do I
excal uh the Israeli government for what
happened now I think the Israeli it's
clear um that President Netanyahu first
of all has nurtured Hamas in many ways
the same way that we nurtured al- Qaeda
and that we nurtured
Isis and he allowed the qataris to give
at least 1.5 billion over the
past three years to Hamas you know um uh
presumably because he thought he was
buying peace um and then you know he
also his very aggressive policies in the
West Bank have moved a lot of the
military resources to the West
Bank and take him off the god god of
fence line but there's a you know do I
blame him I you know I blame him
for uh and leud maybe for um uh uh for
negligence but you know Hamas is Hamas
has to take the full blame for what
happened in in Israel Hamas has been you
know the Israelis have
treated Hamas and Gaza in a way no other
nation of the world would treat an enemy
that declared war on them 16 years ago
and has dropped 30,000 missiles on
Israel how did Israel what did Israel do
instead of going into Gaza which every
other country going just flattened it
they if if the Mexican Government
elected a communist if Mexican people
elected a communist government they
hijack the
government and they said okay we're
we're reclaiming
Texas um and then sent missiles onto San
Antonio and Houston how long would it
take for Mexico to be
flat not long we would go and then what
if they send 3,000 terrorists to slid
people's throat you know burn babies rig
women and all that we would go in there
the
Israelis have done something different
they instead of going into Gaza they
they they built a fence around it you
know now Gaza Hamas says oh you put us
in open air prison yeah cuz you were
sending suicide bombers across the
border we had an open border you were
sending suicide bombers over to kill us
and we had to put the fence up and in in
order to stop the 30,000 missiles they
built an iron dome which we help them
pay
for but when a missile sent over they
shoot down every missile that Hamas
makes cost them about $800 they to shoot
it down cost
$40,000 Israelis have taken that have
said we're going to shoulder that burden
because we don't want to go in
there they thought it was under control
they put up the fence the fence has
cameras on it it's monitoring systems it
has automatic machine guns and it has
balloons that you know look
and because Hamas was being aided by
Iran they got North Korea drones that
were able to shoot down those clues that
were able to disable the defenses and
then they you know they they used
explosives and
tractors to carve these holes in the
fence and Israel up till that moment
felt like this was a tactical issue now
they get more Hamas
Gaza gets more money from the
international Aid Community than any
people on the face of the earth a god
has got more per capita than we gave to
the Marshall Plan to rebuild all of
Europe after World War
II they get the Israelis when they the
Israelis walked out of Gaza unilaterally
said we're giving it to you we don't
want any more disputes they took 9,000
Jewish families who live there in
beautiful houses along the Gaza
Coast they forced them to leave it was
very
unpopular they didn't want their Jewish
Graves to be defaced so they dug up the
Jewish graveyards and brought them out
they removed the IDF and they said we're
going to give you a going away president
to hamama to the Gaza we're going to
give you 3,000 green houses that are
worth a lot of money that make Gaza food
self-sufficient not only that a net food
exporter and for free we are going to
rebuild the port of Gaza which is a
beautiful Port but it's it's it's
inadequate and we're so that you can
make get the Singapore the
West Gaza should be an Eden an economic
Eden with all the money that's been
poured in but what have they done with
the money Hamas they've hijacked their
own
people they have deprived and starved
their own people they've made all of
their leaders billionaires they don't
even live in Gaza they live in DOA and
they live in anra and turkey and DOA and
gutter in huge
palaces and surrounded by guards they
build 300 M of tunnels this is what they
did with the money they were supposed to
bu be building for people poor
Palestinians who were stuck in refugee
camps build them houses we put plenty
concrete money they built 300 miles of
tunnels 1,300
tunnels um and they bought weapons they
bought drones they bought missiles they
tore up the state-of-the-art irrigation
system and that the Israelis had built
you know Gaza is an oasis that's why
it's there it had great fresh water
they've destroyed it they destroyed the
freshwat it's now all saltwater
infiltration CU they stopped regulating
well
drilling they tore up the irrigation
system and they cut the irrigation pipes
into Rockets turn them into
rockets and fired them at Israel 30,000
Rockets before October 7 10,000 C now
one of the things they say is oh the
Israelis are using Collective punishment
to starve us right and we're and but and
and I have friends in Gaza Palestinian
friends and I spent you know I have a
lot of Palestinian friends all over
Israel and the West Bank I've met with
all the Palestinian
leadership in the West
Bank Israel because Gaza mismanage it's
Gaza has plenty of of fresh water it's
all it's they some of the best
deselenization plants in the
world but they don't have any fuel for
it why don't they have fuel first of all
is is because they mismanaged their
water Israel built its own pipes out of
humanitarian
impulse to pump water into Gaza it's
only 9% of the water so they're not
shutting off all the water they shut off
their little 9% why because Hamas bombed
the pipes and then they wouldn't let
food they they Hamas to this day is
sending hundreds of rockets every day
why is Israel going to bring food in
there and get bombed by rockets and fuel
trucks
now Hamas says oh you didn't give us
enough food for the
hospitals Hamas in the tunnels is
storing 1.5 million lers of
fuel and they were starving their own
population they didn't build a single
bomb shelter in all
Gaza they said the tunnels we don't let
them into the population into the
tunnels those are for our Fighters
40,000 Fighters they they're the ones
who get to stay in the tunnels the
population is up there and they put
their armories their fuel
dumps their headquarters their command
headquarters under mosques hospitals
residential housing and schools they use
their civilians as Shields and and we
how do we know they have all this fuel
well there's
proof cuz those weapons and Rockets
they're sending on Israel right now
10,000 since October 7th require huge
amount oun of fuel to fire them so they
were using the fuel for the rockets and
not letting their public get it for the
incubators in the hospital what did
Israel do risk the lives of IDF soldiers
to go into Gaza and bring bring the
incubators enough fuel for those
incubators and they got Hamas told the
hospital administrators if you go to the
corner and pick them up because Israel
left it on the corner they didn't want
to go in there we'll shoot you and so
then Israel sent IDF soldiers to
actually bring it into the hospital now
they say they're targeting civilians
well here's what Israel has done Israel
used high-tech to avoid civilian
casualties it has already it's made
20,000 phone calls with a with Israeli
soldiers who speak Arabic before they
bomb a bill if they're going to bomb a
Target that is a high value Target like
a you know a terrorist and a group they
don't give any
warning 90% of their targets are
infrastructure and they always warn in
advance and they've warned people to go
to the South so that they can root out
the terrorists but they also go
neighborhood by neighborhood and say
tomorrow we're going to bomb your
neighborhood they've they make phone
calls to the landlords and to the
individuals but a lot of their phones
have don't have connectivity now so they
drop leaflets leaflets are colorcoded by
neighborhood and by time so that you you
you know that it was meant for you on
this date you're not picking up an old
leaflet and reading it they've made 1.2
million Robo calls sent 1.2 million
leaflets and then before they bomb an
apartment building they sent A Little
Piece of ordinance a little tiny missile
called a roof
knocker they sent it from a drone or a
helicopter and it goes and hits the top
and everybody knows that's the signal
that with in one hour or two hours that
building is going to be
dropped they warn him what happens Hamas
won't let the people leave it forced
them to stay there because you know
that's how it makes money by killing its
own civilians and there there's never
been an Army in the history of the world
that has been more willing to sacrifice
its mothers its wives its daughters and
its children to the enemy and you know
if you think there's not a moral
difference between Hamas and Israel
consider this what would happen if
Israel decided to use human
Shields do you think Hamas would stop
every Jew in Israel would be killed
hamas's Charter incidentally says it's
against Islam to negotiate with Jews
unless you're F fooling them number two
Israel doesn't exist it is our country
and we are going and and our mission is
to annihilate it number three we're not
only going to kill every Jew in Israel
we're going to kill every Jew in the
world that's in its
Charter and this is an old language they
is H was an RT a week ago saying yeah
that's what we're going to do we're
going to do this again and again and
again and
again telling Israel you've got to
negotiate it's I don't you know what
what are they going to negotiate over is
I they can Hamas considers against a
violation a treasury to Islam to
negotiate with the Israelis I don't see
you know I my heartbreaks for the
Palestinian
people and I have a friend who's there
who has five children who's in South
Gaza right now and I you know sent them
money this
morning and you know their lives are
horrible but I don't blame the israelies
I blame and I you know I'm not
co-signing anything for Netanyahu or lud
um but I I you know I blame I blame
Hamas my concern is as a person who
lived in Iran for 10 years I'm in
America because you know some I
interviewed the Crown Prince of Iran a
couple weeks ago and we had a great
conversation some of the things his
father did he wasn't too paranoid enough
Iran fell us wasn't paranoid enough we
got attacked and maybe Israel wasn't
paranoid enough Hamas attacked them
that's where my question was coming from
but go
forward uh Mr Kennedy thank you for the
opportunity for the question uh before I
heard Joe Rog talk about your book the
real Anthony fouchy I was sadly
misinformed and under the impression
that RFK Jr was a kooky quote unquote
antivaxer if it weren't for Independent
Media sources in podcasts I would have
never had the chance to hear the
thoughts of my now favorite presidential
candidate who I believe may be able to
save and unite our country in this sad
and scary time what do you do plan to do
as president to impower protect and
Elevate Independent Media sources in
podcasts such as pbd and Valu tainment
Jo Rogan Experience crystal ball and
Sager and many more that's a great
question I I can tell you this that on
day
one I'm going to issue a uh executive
order to all federal
employees um making it uh firing offense
to collaborate with media to censor
political speech in this country social
media or
media and that would apply to the CIA
the FBI DHS and all the agencies we now
know from the Twitter files um and other
sources including my litigation you know
which is in the Supreme Court right now
Kennedy versus Biden and Missouri versus
Biden we know from Discovery in those
that they were collaborating with about
with over a dozen agencies to censor
political speech in this country and um
that you know my I started getting
censored 30 by the White House 37 hours
after President Biden took the oath of
office and that is all in um and you
know that's all outlined in 55 page
Federal Court
decision and that's wrong in our country
you know freedom of speech is the
Central Foundation Stone of our country
and uh and there's no time in history
when we look back and say the people who
were censoring speech were the good guys
they're always the bad guys they're you
know it's
always the first step toward total Arian
rule Hamilton Madison Adams said we put
the guarantee of freedom of expression
in the First Amendment because all the
other rights are dependent on it if you
have a government that can silence its
opponent it has license for any
atrocity and you know we all grew up
reading Orwell and uh Aldis Huxley and
uh and you know uh Robert hline and uh
and you know and sulan and
and all of these other writers who were
telling us one after the other in our
civics class and everything else that if
you wanted destroy democracy the first
place you started censoring speech I
thought we all knew that and it is weird
to me that there's so many people in
my know Democratic party who still think
it's okay as long as um the speech or is
Republican speech or it's you know Annie
war or Annie vax or whatever that you're
okay censoring that as long as you don't
SP censor our
speech uh great question by the way one
of the one of the things that a lot of
us um are curious about and we're
enamored by the 60y year anniversary of
your uncle's assassination just recently
uh passed us and every time a president
a candidate is running if I become a
president I'm going to you know release
100% of the files and and then
afterwards they get in like well you
know not necessarily a little bit maybe
maybe later all this stuff for yourself
I know you work with um in California
you actually met Siran Siran if I'm not
mistaken you had a meeting with him and
you stated you believe in the
overwhelming evidence that he is not
your father's killer even writing a
letter to the parole board on his behalf
there is nobody else that's felt a pain
more than the son of a father who was
assassinated who is going to spend his
entire life wanting to find out who was
behind it so there's nobody who has more
moral authority to go to a person who is
claimed to have been the Killer and says
I don't think this guy did it
then eventually you even uh Governor
Nome reversed the decision of the board
parole hearings to Grant parole to Siran
Siran Nome declined the opportunity as
you called it to demonstrate the
humanity compassion idealism of our
justice system to which my father
devoted his life to this is you saying
this so
one you become a president are
you 100% committing to releasing every
data Intel you have even if that means
undermining the CIA which many of these
fear that if you do that the American
people as if they don't trust the CIA
enough it's going to go even lower than
lower than lower you know of where we're
at with that so one are you willing to
commit to that and two when you hear
stories about Siran Siran still being in
jail why is Nome not releasing him yeah
I mean the the uh I I I'm going to
release them you know
immediately at least I I find it odd
that President Biden if first of all
it's illegal not to release them under
the 2017 JFK assassination documents act
everything had to be released you know
so um and by
2017 oh and President Biden committed to
do it and then why do you think we
haven't though I don't know you know the
guy to ask that is President Trump
because president Trump
also committed to it and I don't
understand it I'm not going to pretend
to understand it because president Trump
did not like the CIA so you know you
know clearly they're keeping it quiet
not be everybody who's involved in my
uncle's stas station practically
everybody is
dead the only reason to keep it secret
at this point is is because there's some
institutional liabilities there's
institutional reputational liabilities
that they don't want us to know about
and that's the opposite of democracy
democracy is about transparency it's we
own these agencies they're supposed to
be working for us they they need to tell
us what happened and it's you know it's
the it's the most um uh it's the most
consequential crime of our uh you know
probably of our history and we ought to
know what
happened in terms of my I you know when
I was a little kid I was in the White
House standing next to my uncle's casket
in the East
room and President Johnson comes in and
he tells my mother my father and
Jackie that a jack a man named Jack Ruby
had just killed Lee Harvey Oswald who
had shot my uncle who they say shot my
uncle and at that point I said to my
mother and father I said why did he do
that did he love our family because he
was he did it in a police station and
broad daylight in front of cameras why
would anybody do
that and I said did he love our family
and um you know it turns out he did not
he was a mob and you know uh was all
involved with the people that my father
was putting in jail but deeply involved
with the
CIA and this kind of gun running
subculture that was you know involved
with
Cuba and but at that point my little
10-year-old mind was saying this makes
no sense and you know I don't think it
made sense to anybody but I always
assumed Siran killed my father he
confessed to the
crime he had a um you know he said he
didn't remember
anything but he pled guilty and he
didn't have a trial he had a kind of a
sensing hearing because he he pled
guilty I'm not so I always assumed it
and then a man named Paul shra who' been
a very close friend of my father's and
and political associate he was one of
the top deputies of the United Auto
Workers and he had introduced my father
to Cesar Chavez and recruited Cesar
shave to the labor movement so he was
very Clos you know say shavez became you
know one of the most my my father's most
important political
allies shade was standing next to my
father when the shooting started and he
took the first bullet to his
head and he's you know he was okay in
the long run but he was shot in the
head Siran fired two shots of my father
the first one hit Paul
shra the second and Paul trade
incidentally tell the punchline called
me and said um you know I don't know 10
years ago and said I want you to come to
my house and read the autopsy report on
your
dad this you can imagine the last thing
in the world that I ever wanted to do
but I couldn't say no to him because he
had taken a bullet for my
father and he was a good friend so I
went and talked to
him and he showed me the autopsy report
and then you know a lot of other
information but essentially after
reading that it was impossible for me to
believe that Siran had killed my dad
I'll tell you why Paul two Siran fired
two shots of my father the first one he
hit my father hit put Paul sh the had
the second
one hit a door jam a wooden door jam
behind my father and was later removed
from that door jam by the
LAPD that at that point he was grabbed
it was a crowded room there's 77 people
in the
room in the kitchen and he was standing
in front of a steam table my father was
5et in front of him my father never
turned his back all kinds of
eyewitnesses he was grabbed by six men
including raer Johnson who I've talked
to about at Rosie career you know was
part of the Fearsome forsome um Oakland
Raiders um and and four other guys men
and they piled on top of them Ray for
Johnson said to me suran is a little
tiny guy and almost feeble look I mean
today he's feeble looking I spent about
three hours with him in jail you know
sitting in the prison with him his these
men took his hand the first thing they
did and pointed away from my father but
rer Johnson
said uh toward the other end of the room
raer Johnson said to me raer Johnson was
that the cathon champion 1960 a huge guy
super strong and he
said this little man had superum
strength and I could not get the gun
away from him and he emptied the
revolver it was a revolver he emptied it
he had eight shots in it and he never
reloaded and he shot six times in the
other direction all six of those bullets
hit people five of
them um one of them had had made you
know went through one one guy's clothing
and another it also wounded his leg he
he h people in the stomach it all we
know what happened every one of those
bullets right that's eight bullets we
know what happened to every one of
them my father the autopsy report shows
was shot four times from
behind he and they were contact shot one
of them went through one of them did not
hurt him but went through the uh
shoulder pad of his
jacket the other ones all hit him and
the last one which was the most fatal
was right behind his ear an inch from
his ear but with the barrel touching his
skin and the other ones were all contact
shots meaning that they were within
probably a half an
inch of his skin and clothing and they
left carbon tattoos on his
skin and Siran was never behind my
father and there was many many
eyewitnesses oh the guy who almost
certainly fired that shot those shots
was a man called Eugene than Cesar and
Eugene Cesar died a year and a half ago
in the Philippines I was in
conversations trying to see him and he
said he would talk to me and I had to
pay him $10,000 and then he when I was
about to leave he said now now I want
20,000 and then he said I want 25,000
and I realize he's you know playing me
so I didn't
go oh um he was a security
guard who had gotten the job the day
before when people already knew where my
father was going his real
job was in the he originally worked for
Hughes tool in a which is a military
contractor owned by Howard
use and run by a lot of guys from Las
Vegas and then he went to Boeing and
locki and he had top secret clearance
and he was he described himself Lisa
peas who's an attorne who's an
author found documents where he
describes himself as a CIA
agent um so uh and he P public was very
public about his hatred for my father
that he thought my father was going
to turn the country over to black people
and um he uh and you know he then lied
continuously to the police by the way my
father when he fell fell onto Cesar and
Cesar was under Cesar escorted him he
wasn't supposed to go into the kitchen
he grabbed him by his his elbow and
escorted him into the
Ambush suran's Ambush and presumably
while suran was shooting and everybody
could see this man firing he was quietly
the the the bullets and my
father the gun was laying against skin
and all of them were on an upward
trajectory this is what the autopsy
report
shows and um my father must have known
that he was being shot by suran because
he turned and pulled off as he was
falling he pulled off Cesar's clip on
tie and if you see the pictures of my
father lying on the
ground some of the early ones have a
clip on top and my father my mother took
that out and put a Rosary in my dad's
hand oh but the original ones have that
clip on tie and Cesar there's picture of
Cesar with no tie on and
uh the
um and so you know he he would and and
by the way 12
people saw him when he got up he pushed
my father's off of him and stood up and
he had his gun drawn and when the police
came he said he had pulled his gun to
fire at Siran
but they never confiscated his gun and
then he lied about the gun later and you
know the gun is now been
recovered it had a very weird Journey it
was stolen it was thrown into a lake by
some teenagers the lake was drained and
that there's a guy now the gun is now
being tested
but um it it's clear that uh
Siran was
involved and there's a long long
backstory to that to what made have
might have happened that I'm not going
to talk about or speculate because it's
a long
story um but that he did not actually
fire the shots that killed my dad oh do
you think the same reason why no
president is given the entire
information of what happened with your
uncle's assassination is the same reason
why Governor nuum isn't releasing Siran
Siran do you think those two are the
same reason no I think I think news him
you know had a good relationship with me
okay and he would have done it he parted
with me on the co I became very critical
of them and then there's a number of
members of my
family who have um who just wants her
hand in jail and they they have not my
family my family got it and I understand
them I have total compassion for them
and I you know I don't have any
resentments or anything any differences
with them I they're
wrong um and I
also my family you know was was what the
whole nation was traumatized by my dad's
death my family was directly traumatized
by his death and most of them cannot
bear to read anything about the
assassination even when we were
kids any of you not my age know
particularly when the zder tapes came
out with my uncle assassination they
were played constantly on TV all the
time and that those
pictures those videos on TV of of you
know my uncle waving from the back of
the convertible with his beautiful wife
Jackie sitting next to him and then you
know bowing over in the car those those
were played I don't know how many times
on TV when I was a kid millions of times
they were played again and again and
again when those came on the TV in my
house somebody would go and turn off the
TV because everybody was traumatized by
it and today to this
day I'm probably the only one in my
family um who's actually read done
research on the assassination who's been
to De Plaza
who's written about it and I wrote a
book my own book American values that
talks about the 60y year which my bi
biography but it's about the 60y year
battle that my family had with the
CIA and um so you know I I understand my
my family wants that closure and they
want you know they don't want this they
don't want Siran out on the street with
news people following them reminding
them feeling uncomfortable to come to
Los Angeles cuz he's walking around and
you know um and them uh being you know
resentful at me for getting involved in
this issue and resuscitating all the
pain and Trauma that they had I get it
and I support that but I you know I
don't agree with them uh you know for
for us it's different because we're
curious for you it's personal because
it's your life it's it's what you
experience do you uh uh do you when
you're talking about this are you
comfortable talking about this does it
is this one of the reasons why you are
choosing to run is this one of the
reasons why you're so driven and
determined to go out there and maybe get
to the bottom of the truth for your
family's
Legacy there I would not run for
president for this reason I think it is
important for
Americans because I think we took a a a
um that was a fork in the road for
American democracy you know my father my
my a when when three days before my
uncle took
office the outgoing president President
Eisenhower gave what I think we should
today regard as the most important
speech in American history where he
warned Americans against the domination
you know this
emerging military industrial complex
that would turn us into an Imperium
abroad in a National Security State at
home and and and
destroy our role as the world's
exemplary democracy and he had been the
commander chief in World War II so his
words were very important and then my
uncle I was on my birthday in 1960
January
17 61 my my uncle takes office 3 days
later and then his thousand days in
office are eight are just a constant
fist fight with the military industrial
complex to keep the country out of War
they kept trying to trick him into
war they did it at the Bay of Pigs 3
months in they tell him you got to send
these guys over and he said I'm not use
the military to invade a country that
you know I don't like communism I don't
like
CASRO but the Cubans have to have to
make their own determination about what
kind of government they're going to have
the US can't go into all these other
countries and change governments
around and he said I don't want the mil
US military involved I don't think we
should be involved in any part of it
and they said don't
worry we'll use United Fruit Company um
boats to get them in there and he said
I'm not giving air cover I just want you
to know that they said don't worry you
won't need it and he said some why CASRO
has 200,000 soldiers in the best
intelligence agencies
and why do you think 2,000 men are going
to be able to you know win this battle
and they said because we have the whole
thing re wired and rigged and there's
going to be a big uh Uprising in Cuba
and it's all done this When Alan Dulles
told
him Richard
Bissell Charles Cabella was the military
general of the
CIA he he suspected that but he couldn't
believe they just lying to him and you
know when those men were dying on the
beach and they were telling now you got
to send in an air cover you got to send
in the essic the aircraft
he said I'm not and he realized he'd
been tricked and they thought a young
president would you know cave in to
avoid
humiliation it was the lowest point of
my uncle's presidency that those men
were dying because of his bad
decision and he took the blame publicly
but privately he said I want to take the
CIA and shatter it into a thousand
pieces and Scatter it to the
winds and then over the next couple
months he fired Dulles he fired cabel he
hard bisle and he tried to clean up the
agency and um and then you know they
tried to get him to go into La he
refused they they called him a traitor
for that they tried to get him to go
into Cuba in 61 and again in' 62 during
the Missile Crisis and he wouldn't send
it he wouldn't you know go
invade they tried to get him to go in
Berlin in ' 62 and he wouldn't they
tried to get him to go in
Vietnam they said you need 250,000
troops his closest advis people he
trusted like Max h ail Aram and Dean
aeson they said if you don't send in
250,000 troops the Vietnamese government
is going to collapse and he said it's
their government it can't be our fight
you know we can help them the way the
French helped us During the Revolution
but we cannot fight this cannot be the
American
war and uh he did send in 16,000
advisors they were not under the rules
engagement allowed to participate in
combat they were mainly Green
Berets and then and were fewer people
than he sent to the University of
Mississippi to Old Miz to get one black
man in right to college was few people
but then he found out in October of uh
62 of
63 he found out a Green Beret had
died and he asked Walt Rosal for a
casualty list and Walt Rosal came back
and said there's 75 Americans already
died over
there my uncle said that's too many
we're bringing them all home and that
that afternoon he signed National
Security order
263 ordering all military personnel out
of Vietnam with the first thousand
coming home in November and the last one
coming home uh the following
December and um he he 30 days to the day
after he signed that order he was
murdered and a week after that President
Johnson remanded the order and then sent
250,000 troops
in Nix and in in uh after him sent
560,000
56,000 never came home of our guys we
killed a million of them 56,000 of ours
never came home including my cousin
George skle who died in the T
offensive and then you know my father
ran against the war in 68 he wins the
California primary meaning he's on his
way to the White House and he shot that
night Martin Luther King had become a
peace activist two months before he was
shot
these traumas my uncle's death my father
King's death the Vietnam War
itself 91 and Co each one of these
traumas pushed us a little farther down
that
road that Eisenhower warned us against
we're today you know we are the military
industrial complex our
our our democracy nobody in this country
believes that their voices are audible
in Washington you know everything is
rigged and everybody knows that it's
like the Kabuki theater of of a
democracy it's not real it's a Hollywood
stage set with you know people
pretending to have elections that are
already chosen in advance and everything
else and I'm not being paranoid just
look what's happening right now so um
you know I
think part of unraveling that and and
going back to our original idealism and
the other view of an American future and
you know is America is the exemplary
nation and the moral Authority around
the globe means going back and you know
looking at the original trauma and fig
and and exposing what actually happened
to my uncle I think one thing that's
very uh um appealing and attractive to
you as a candidate is millions on top of
millions of Americans are sick and tired
of there being a lack of accountability
and not being told what's taking place I
have 50 more questions I can ask you but
we're at the end of the uh uh Town Hall
here I appreciate you for coming up for
the folks that are watching out there
you can go to
kennedy4 docomo the QR code is on the
bottom right of the screen while you're
looking at us everybody in here
appreciate you guys for coming up and
last but not least Bobby for from you
coming out here telling the stories I
could have gone two more hours with you
sincerely I learned I'm like your nephew
there is like well you know I was going
to school I'm like what are you studying
political sign that makes sense I took a
year break to do this I'm like like dude
you're going to get a PhD on political
science being around you once again
appreciate you for coming out thank you
so much thank
[Applause]
you
yellow mic Vinnie